- Max?
- Ja?
- Kannst du morgen vielleicht
etwas früher kommen?
Morgen ist doch der zweiundzwanzigste
und ich hab um halb eins einen Termin.
- Ja, kein Problem.
Übermorgen auch?
- Übermorgen?
Äh, also am dreiundzwanzigsten?
- Kleiner Tipp: Morgen ist der
zweiundzwanzigste,
dann ist übermorgen der …
dreiundzwanzigste.
- Sehr witzig …
Äh, nein, übermorgen habe ich
mittags keine Termine. Nur morgen.
- Okay. Ähm, aber denkst du dran:
Vom ersten bis zum siebten November
hab' ich noch mal Frühdienst.
- Vom ersten bis zum siebten November.
Ja! Das habe ich auch so in
meinem Kalender stehen.
- Cool, okay!
- „Das Marek“, hier ist Tarek!
Hallo.
Ja, auch am Wochenende öffnen wir
morgens um neun
und schließen abends um elf Uhr.
Ja!
Heute Abend?
Sie möchten einen Tisch reservieren?
Ähm,
hm.
Um Viertel vor sieben …
Tut mir leid. Wir haben leider erst um
Viertel vor acht einen Tisch frei.
Am Fenster, natürlich.
Alles klar.
Okay. Wir freuen uns auf Sie!
Danke! Auf Wiederhören!
Danke, Nico. Für deine Hilfe!
- Das mache ich gern.